bien alma el 2017 fue el año en el que
se popularizó el mitú con las denuncias
contra los abusos de poder y
consecuentes vejaciones sexuales contra
mujeres en el medio el caso de Harvey
weinstein es probablemente el más
emblemático seis años después porque
sigue pesando tanto la emisión de
condenas en su contra
Bueno yo creo que como tú bien lo dices
pues este es un caso que representa un
patrón en la industria principalmente
cinematográfica y que Revela la
importancia de que el acoso sexual y la
violación
sexual pues estén sancionadas y y yo
creo que se da un mensaje de que no va a
haber más impunidad ante estos crímenes
a mí me parece pues importante que la
justicia así esté investigando y este
sancionando a personajes que
utilizan poder y su posición para
obligar a las mujeres
de la modelo pues hubo violación
Entonces ahí sí pues me parece que que
la Cia está mandando un un mensaje de no
impunidad Y eso es muy importante un
mensaje que además en los últimos años
amplió el movimiento a otras esferas de
la vida no solamente a Hollywood y Le
quiero preguntar en qué está actualmente
el movimiento y más importante Cómo ha
evolucionado a partir de ello la defensa
de los derechos de las mujeres dentro y
fuera de Estados Unidos
Pues mira en América Latina ha tenido un
gran impacto
las las mujeres están cada vez más
utilizando las redes sociales y
especialmente el Twitter o también se ha
fomentado mucho el periodismo feminista
recientemente
dos periodistas
Catalina Ruiz Navarro y Matilde de los
milagros hicieron una investigación de
otro director Ciro guerra
que también nacido presuntamente
acusado de acoso sexual a varias mujeres
y y pues ya hubo una sentencia de la
corte constitucional
o porque el promovió una tutela diciendo
que se había violado su derecho al buen
nombre Entonces ya estamos viendo como
este tipo de casos están trascendiendo Y
es muy importante pues la corte
constitucional de Colombia lo que dijo
Es que no le va tutelar los derechos así
o porque la violencia de género es un
discurso protegido Y eso qué quiere
decir que no se puede que no es
violatorio de la intimidad de alguien
porque él es una figura pública
reconocida y también tiene que estar
pues al escrutinio público y más allá de
eso el periodismo de investigación que
dé a conocer este tipo de de crímenes
porque las mujeres tienen más confianza
para ir con las periodistas que a la
justicia
Lamentablemente Pues también estarán
protegidas por los tribunales bien alma
y tener presente en todo caso que a
pesar de los avances denunciar violencia
machista sigue siendo una decisión casi
suicida para las mujeres que todavía
somos señaladas como responsables por
esos abusos que sufrimos gracias a usted
alma Beltrán y Puga abogada feminista y
doctora en derecho